at around 8 20 a.m central patrol
officers responded to an attempt suicide
radio call at a residence in the 100
block of west 5th street
while driving to the residence the
officers received an additional call for
a los angeles fire department backup
request at the same location
here is the call and corresponding radio
broadcast for this incident
and 1x95 1x95 fds requesting backup west
history
with this street blizzard patient fifth
floor hallway let's go through some 1069
rd154
when officers arrived they attempted to
communicate with the suspect from a
distance to de-escalate the situation
and encourage the suspect to step out of
the residence to be treated
the suspect however refused to cooperate
with the officers barricaded himself
inside the apartment and pointed a
handgun in their direction
that suspect was identified as laurent
howard james
[Music]
here is body worn video from the
officers involved in this incident
can we see both your hands
right here i see right our right hand
we just want to help you man no one's in
trouble
nobody's in trouble
just put everything down and come out
here so we can talk okay
come on just come out here leave
everything on the ground
let's talk
who's that
right nobody here for you man
you got any guns in there or not
you don't know huh you know what the
hell you have in your apartment
you have guns in your
apartment you have knives in there
disengage
the police may use tactics
[Applause]
me i cannot help you anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do it now
walk towards the door slowly with your
hands up holding nothing in your hands
you're doing really good
come on back slowly
walk slowly towards the front door in
the hallway
walk backwards
[Applause]
it's only going to get worse
walk backwards
there is nothing in the hallway make
your way to the hallway slowly you can
do it
once you get to the hallway i'll be
right there to
you can do it just do it slowly and
focus
walk backwards towards the hallway
i can just see his head
[Music]
sir three looks like he's trying to
climb out the window
oh
two three he is
trying to climb up the window
and
one leg on the ledge
three shot away the suspect is down
just inside the level